hello there it's a new week in fortnite
OG and we've jumped forward in time to
the events of season 6 Kevin the cube
has risen up and taken with it loot
Lake's house this narrative is about to
change the timeline forever I'm Adam I
have manlu right now sorry if my voice
is a little shaky let's do
this less than 7 days ago we arrived on
the old Island as agent Jones crash
landed with the time machine we stole he
was given a plan by Dr to Sloan although
we never heard it for ourselves we know
it has something to do with the time
machine and heisting something Back to
the Future right now the time machine
has moved to the edge of loot Lake where
Kevin floats above us with a new
location comes a new voice recording
from Sloan Jones Sloan here I feel like
I've done this before unless this is
deja vu you're back here for a reason
and it's not to change the future by the
way this is an extraction and you're
leading the way you cannot hesitate in
your duty jump
the world you're leaving is one of many
and there are more worlds than even you
can imagine it seems that Dr Sloan feels
like she sent this message before which
we know she did last week yet she is
unaware of it this is due to the
butterfly effect theoretically changing
one thing back in time ripples forward
and changes the future which is Sloan's
version of reality right now whatever we
and more importantly Jones does Here and
Now is going to change our future
potentially eradicating everything we
been through in the Last 5 Years by
severing this timeline from others we
would never find the law of the loop
thanks to Batman we would never let
Ariana Grande foolers into serving the
cube Queen and remember that time
Wolverine and one of the seven yeah you
remember that would be gone too the
reset button would be pressed and time
would reset let me throw a ridiculous
Theory your way what if the person we
are here to extract was present at two
Live Events but we never saw her what if
we are looking for the person who
oversaw all of reality and protected the
zero point think back to season 8 of
chapter 1 and the
unolingo busy smashing the drum gun you
would have noticed the zero point sat in
Harmony and a desk in front of it what
if we are here to take Singularity Back
to the Future the woman who created the
mech what an event that was and she
casually had her own statue become a
freaking sword we know Singularity is
important to the story and we've been
waiting 4 years for something to happen
do you remember When Donald mustard
confirmed her importance could you draw
a character that's way more important to
the ongoing fortnite story line than we
all realize I drew who you guys know one
of her names as the
singularity uh this is a super super
important character this is just a
theory though I thought I'd throw it out
there Jones looks to be transporting the
time machine to Dusty divot and just
like the scientists before him he's
erected a rocket launching Bay I would
say the scientist is doing this right
now yet he's nowhere in sight as his
meteor never landed here or at least not
yet a cool touch from the fortnite devs
was a clue all along in the truck used
to transport the time machine check out
a rocket ship on the dash maybe a
reminder sent by Sloan or just a cool
Easter egg so we knew where it was going
all along right now Jon's is taking a
break by The wat's Edge and we are one
step closer to understanding his plan
could Kevin the cube be part of it over
at Dusty the crane is completely erected
and the Thruster Bay is already cut out
ready for the rocket ship to launch from
this very location the person doing this
has gone so far to take down all the
artwork on the walls of the diner
including the OG OG Dusty Depot and the
place the original meteor landed I was
hoping now to break into other map
changes but there doesn't seem to be any
at all there are no corrupted areas from
Kevin's movements there is no parachute
signaling the ice biome coming in the
South and the awesome spooky Castle
never arrived in the Hills above the
grave s sites and worst of all
Hut watch remains perfectly intact which
means Hut watch never happened in this
timeline this is this is a sad day in
fact it's so sad I can't go on I'm going
now I'm Adam you're awesome it's been a
pleasure I'll see you next week